Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour à tous.
Merci d’être avec nous et d’être
avec moi pour cette introduction.
Coach, c’est la fonction que je tiens
dans ce TEDx depuis quelque temps.
J’en suis ravi, d’ailleurs.
D’habitude, je suis assis là,
je fais quelques signes.
Je vais arrêter de faire des signes
car j’ai vu à la répétition
que ça déstabilise.
Je suis là parce que je voudrais
partager avec vous une idée
et c’est pour cette raison
que je suis sur la scène.
Cette idée concerne quelque chose
qui va nous occuper toute l’après-midi
car vous allez entendre des histoires
et je vais vous parler de ça.
Ça vous concerne aussi parce que
nous racontons tous des histoires
et je pense qu’on vous demandera
professionnellement
de raconter des histoires également.
Comme je le propose ou suggère à
certains de nos intervenants quelquefois,
je vais commencer par la fin.
Je vais vous donner ma conclusion
tout de suite.
L’idée que je voulais partager
tient d’une question :
«Est-ce que panser le monde,
ça ne pourrait pas être aussi un petit peu
penser l’histoire qui raconte le monde ?»
C'est ce que je voudrais
essayer de démontrer.
Il y a deux choses que
je voudrais dire, c’est que -
vous le savez tous, Il suffit de brancher
votre smartphone ou votre télévision -
des histoires, nous en avons
tous les jours,
nous en vivons tous les jours,
nous en entendons tous les jours.
Nous baignons dans un monde d’histoires.
D’ailleurs, la deuxième chose que
je voudrais dire ici clairement,
dans une école scientifique,
une grande école d’ingénieurs,
demande un argument scientifique,
qui d’ailleurs va rejoindre
votre, notre expérience depuis tout petit.
Et aussi l’expérience de l’humanité
depuis 300 000 ans,
depuis qu’il y a des feux de camp
et des gens autour.
La meilleure façon de passer
une idée à quelqu’un,
c’est de lui raconter une histoire.
Alors, tout à l’heure, vous allez
entendre pas mal d’histoires.
Et mon challenges à moi,
que je me donne devant vous,
c’est de vous raconter quelque chose
en mode histoire, sans aucune anecdote,
car vous allez en avoir
plein cet après-midi,
faites-moi confiance.
Je vais simplement essayer d’étayer
mon propos en mode histoire.
Parce que très souvent, on me demande :
« Mais qu’est-ce qu’une histoire ? »
Vous savez ce qu’est une histoire,
mais en fait, on veut savoir
ce qu’est une bonne histoire,
le truc qui marche !
Je n’ai pas vraiment de recette.
Simplement, il y a six composants.
Six composants.
Le premier composant,
c’est le personnage - pas le coach -
c’est le personnage.
Il vous faut un personnage, un personnage
qui va incarner votre propos.
Et puis, il vous faut un but.
Je vous ai donné tout de suite le but.
Le but, c'est ma conclusion.
Généralement, je dis : «Voilà, c’est le
buisson de l’autre côté de la rivière,
qu’on va traverser avec tout le public.»
Je vous ai donné mon but, ma conclusion.
Je vous ai donné aussi mon intention,
le troisième point :
c’était de faire cette ouverture
et de partager ce qu’est une histoire,
puisque vous allez avoir
plein d’histoires, aujourd’hui.
Alors, il faut aussi que ce soit quelque
chose d’important, il faut un enjeu.
Je vais reprendre ce qu’est l’enjeu.
L’enjeu, c’est que nous vivons dans
une société où il y a plein d’histoires,
et où pour vous, le storytelling,
cette capacité à raconter des histoires,
devient un enjeu majeur,
personnel et professionnel.
Et puis, si le Petit Chaperon rouge
ne rencontrait pas le loup,
il n’y aurait pas d’histoire.
Donc il faut une épreuve.
Je ne vous raconte pas une anecdote.
Il faut donc que dans mon raisonnement,
je rencontre une difficulté que
je vais essayer de résoudre.
Et si j’y arrive, la solution va
peut-être nous servir de leçon.
C’est comme ça que sont créés
tous les contes.
Depuis tout petit,
on apprend ça à notre insu.
D’ailleurs, quand je dirai :
«Ah, ça ne marche pas comme ça»,
vous saurez que j’ai rencontré l’épreuve.
Le cinquième point.
Alors, comme vous êtes tous et toutes
des scientifiques,
vous avez tous déjà su compter
jusqu’à cinq et j’avais dit six,
n’est-ce pas ?
Le sixième point est très important
parce que c’est celui qui va me permettre
de répondre à la deuxième question :
«Une bonne histoire, c’est quoi ?»
Eh bien, ce point-là, ce sont les détails.
Pour vous raconter quelque chose
qui ait du sens pour vous,
il faut que nous partagions
quelques détails.
Sinon on ne sera pas certains de savoir
que nous parlons bien de la même chose.
Moi, je vous ai donné des détails
liés à mon sujet,
c’est-à-dire l’histoire,
mes constituants de l’histoire.
Mes six constituants sont mes détails.
J’espère que vous avez pu
vous y reconnaître,
racontant ou en entendant une histoire.
Personnages, etc.
bon, passons, je ne refais pas.
Ces six constituants sont mes détails,
vous les avez.
Mais il ne faut pas que j'en donne trop.
D’abord parce que le timing va exploser.
Et aussi parce qu’il y a
un point très important,
c’est que à la place de donner
certains détails parfois superflus,
il importe de laisser des trous,
des trous dans l’histoire,
des trous dans le canevas,
de façon à ce que ceux qui écoutent
puissent mettre leurs propres détails,
leur propre vécu.
et ainsi le fin du fin de l’histoire,
de la bonne histoire,
ce n’est pas tellement celle
de celui qui la raconte,
mais plutôt celle de celui qui l’écoute.
Et c'est comme ça que vous adhérez.
C’est ce que j’espère.
Je suis sûr que vous allez le faire
quand vous aurez entendu les histoires
qui viennent après moi.
Alors, il y a des gens
qui savent le faire.
Vous savez déjà le faire.
mais il y a des pros
qui savent déjà le faire.
Dès que vous avez
la moindre responsabilité,
quel que soit votre niveau dans
la société, on vous demande ça.
Les politiques, par exemple, se tournent
vers les communicants
pour leur demander la bonne histoire.
Ils appellent ça les éléments de langage.
Je n’irai pas plus loin
car ce serait malvenu de ma part.
Mais l’idée derrière, c’est quand même
vachement difficile de panser le monde
avec un pansement -
changer le monde, c’est très compliqué.
Et si, à la place, on racontait
une bonne histoire, ça serait génial.
Ah, c'est là que ça devient difficile.
Ah, ça ne marche pas comme ça.
je le sais parce que les médias
et tout le monde le disent.
Depuis une trentaine d’années,
tous les sociologues nous disent
que nous vivons dans
une société désenchantée.
Nous avons perdu quoi ?
Le sens !
Ouais, il y a personne qui suit ...
Nous avons perdu le sens.
Mais vous allez dans n’importe
quelle DRH de grandes entreprises,
très vite, on va vous dire :
«Le boulot du manager, du chef de projet,
c’est de donner le sens.»
Et pour ça, rien de mieux
que de raconter la bonne histoire.
Et le problème, c’est qu’hélas,
on nous en raconte tellement,
c’est ce que je disais tout à l’heure,
qu’aujourd’hui on nous parle
de l’éditorialisation du monde.
Vous avez sûrement fait
cette expérience-là.
Depuis quelques années, c’est flagrant.
Vous avez un titre de 14 mots
en bas de l’écran
quand vous regardez
une chaîne d’info continue
et pendant cinq heures, des gens passent
et vous racontent l’histoire,
en continu, 5 heures, 14 mots.
Donc on n'y croit plus.
C’est fini, il y a trop de baratin,
ce n’est pas possible.
Alors, que faire face à ça ?
Il y a un sociologue, dont je vous
recommande le bouquin,
qui a écrit un livre intitulé
«l’Apocalypse cognitive».
Je me suis demandé si ce n’était pas
la véritable pandémie de notre temps.
l’Apocalypse cognitive.
Le trop plein d’informations,
d’histoires, d’éditorialisation.
Alors, que peut-on faire face à ça ?
La première chose serait d’arrêter tout,
de ne plus raconter d’histoires.
Vous ne seriez pas là, moi non plus ;
fini, plus d’histoires.
Le truc, c’est que ce n’est pas possible,
parce que les neuroscientifiques que j’ai
évoqués tout à l’heure, nous le disent.
Si je dis : pas d’histoire,
vous allez dire : «Mais c’est quoi
cette histoire ?», pas vrai ?
En fait, on va chercher
à se raconter une histoire.
C’est un complot, on nous empêche
de nous raconter des histoires.
Donc, la première solution ne marche pas,
ça n’en est pas une.
Il y a plus malin.
Je vous ai trouvé une citation du
président Jefferson, homme politique,
qui disait très malicieusement :
«Le mensonge seulement,
a besoin de l’aide de l’État.
La vérité, elle, peut se débrouiller
toute seule.»
En clair, ça voudrait dire
que quand on a la vérité,
quand on a quelque chose
de vraiment vrai à dire,
peu importe de s’occuper de l’histoire.
Je crois qu’il se trompait complètement.
C’est mon job.
Donc, je crois qu’il se trompait
complètement.
Je pense, comme dans la très
ancienne tradition hébraïque,
c’est dans la Bible,
que la vérité se promène
dans les vêtements de la parabole.
J’aime beaucoup cette phrase-là.
Ça veut dire qu’il faut
quand même y réfléchir.
Il faut se préparer
car la concurrence médiatique
et la concurrence des histoires -
vous allez voir cet après-midi,
il y a une sacrée concurrence
d’histoires intéressantes -
eh bien, elle est là,
donc il faut y faire quelque chose.
Donc, il faut s’y préparer
et c’est ce qu’on fait.
C’est ce qu’on a fait avec toute l’équipe
et avec nos brillants speakers
que vous allez voir tout à l’heure.
Et, on s’est dit que,
cette histoire, elle allait se dérouler
avec quelque chose d’un petit peu désuet,
quelque chose que l’on n’a pas,
finalement, trop l’habitude de trouver.
Moi, je vous garantis cela.
Je ne sais pas si c’est vrai,
mais ce que je sais,
c’est que c’est sincère.
Je vous ai trouvé cette citation,
que j’aime beaucoup
et elle est à la mode,
en cette période de pandémie.
Voilà ce que disait Camus.
Il y a plein de gens
qui relisent ce roman.
«La seule façon de lutter contre
la peste, c’est l’honnêteté.»
Alors, ça vous paraît peut-être
un peu lourd, un peu désuet,
carrément bisounours même,
certains pourraient poser la question.
Eh bien, quand on est dans la sincérité,
ça permet de nous mettre sur le chemin
d’un contenu un peu plus authentique.
Et si en plus, vous avez pris garde
d’y laisser des trous,
de façon à ce qui vous a intéressé
vienne vous interpeler
pour que vous y mettiez du vôtre,
que vous creusiez,
que vous alliez un peu au-delà -
vous verrez, on vous interpellera
cet après-midi -
alors c’est que peut-être, vous avez
commencé à prendre le chemin
de votre vérité.
C'est ça qu'on cherche à faire
dans nos histoires à nous.
Et voilà pourquoi, mesdames et messieurs,
je vous ai dit tout à l’heure
que panser le monde,
ça pourrait être penser
l’histoire qui en rend compte.
Alors moi qui sais que ce n’est pas si
facile de raconter une histoire sincère,
vous verrez ça tout à l’heure,
j’espère que vous prendrez autant
de plaisir à écouter ces histoires-là
que nous, nous en avons eu
à travailler avec nos speakers.
Et pour reprendre la petite phrase
de la vidéo que vous venez de voir :
«Now, on with the show ! »
(Applaudissements)